my name is priya natarajan
i'm an astrophysicist and uh at the
faculty at yale in the departments of
astronomy and physics
i am also currently the director of
yale's flagship
interdisciplinary program the frankie
program in science and the humanities
and it is my real pleasure
today to set off a new series
a themed series of questions
about the nature of inference
understanding the nature of inference
trying to discern the role of causation
correlation
these sort of deeper questions that are
very very important
to really disentangle and so this is a
series
that is supported by uh some
funds from the john templeton foundation
and what we are going to do as part of
this series is have a multi-disciplinary
exploration
on the question of inference and how
inference
how we infer in different fields
philosophy computer science physics
biology
organizational behavior how we actually
build conceptual models and these can be
models that are either numerical
computational and how we make inferences
so
and as you all know there's a bit of a
bandwagon right now with machine
learning and big data and so on but
one of the key sort of deeper issues
that isn't resolved yet
and you know machine learning aspires to
get there is really helping disentangle
causation and correlation and fields
like physics have a lot to offer because
we have this grand architecture of
physics laws
laws of physics that govern cause and
effect
and help us therefore figure out and
discriminate between
uh causation and mere correlation so uh
to speaking to this question and talking
about the deep
roots of understanding causes and
effects we have a wonderful speaker
today
inaugurating uh our series
uh and that is uh carlo rovelli um
and uh before i uh give a wonderful
gushy introduction
uh because i'm a great admirer of his
work
his writing and his thinking i just want
to
give a shout out to our benefactors
richard and barbara frankie who i hope
have joined us today
thanks to their generosity uh at the
frankie program
we have been able to run these wonderful
events
and we have not allowed the pandemic to
scupper
our enthusiasm to explore things
intellectually thank you very much
and i also want to remind all of you
that we are recording this event
and all participants must therefore mute
their videos
as everyone seems to have done and
we so the format of the talk is that
carlo will speak for about an hour and
then we open up to questions
and we will be managing questions
through the chat so please type in your
questions
uh in the chat and then we will pass
them on we will tie an eye
we'll pass them on and i just want to
also say thanks to dr ty
camp who is the assistant director of
the frankie program
and has really helped with uh
advertising and pulling this uh event as
well as the series together
want to give a shout out to many future
speakers in our series who are there
today
uh and i welcome you all um uh
so and and thank you and um i think
that um the one other
thing i wanted to mention is that
following uh
today's talk we have at the same time uh
a discussion with the same
zoom length that you can join tomorrow
and that would be sort of a
follow-up more in-depth discussion uh
and a conversation between carlo and one
of our core project members dr eric
winsberg
so i invite you all to attend that uh i
promise you it's going to be a real
double treat with uh today
and tomorrow okay so um most of you
uh i don't really he uh carlo doesn't
really need an introduction but you know
i i love to give these introductions
because
um it's just remarkable to see the paths
of
the life paths of people um and the
places that they have
kind of inhabited the roles they have
inhabited uh
to reach where they are now so as most
of you know
uh carlo is a theoretical physicist who
is very well known for his work on
quantum gravity particularly loop
quantum gravity
and also the foundations of physics
questions and
deep questions deeper questions about
quantum mechanics
and overall sort of more generally
interested in the history of ideas so
he's interested in the history and
philosophy of science
and one of the things that has been
wonderful for me to uh
to have uh found out about carlo is that
you know he has this
incredible expansive mind and has been
interested in exploring
sort of non-european sources of thinking
and rightly recognizing that uh
a work intellectual work follows an arc
and there are many people
who make contributions and offer uh sort
of new insights
so we have recently uh talked about
the work of the buddhist philosopher
nagarjuna
who is a great fan favorite with both of
us
so carlo was born in italy and graduated
from the universities of bologna and
paduva and he has worked
in italy the united states france and
canada
right now he heads the quantum gravity
group of the center for theoretical
physics at
uh at marseilles um he's a member of the
institute uh universite de france
he's an honorary professor at beijing
normal university
and he's a honoris uh has an
honorary doctorate from the university
of sao martin
in buenos aires he's a member of the
international academy of philosophy and
sciences
you know his list of awards just goes on
and on and on
so i will just uh sort of stop with just
1995 because it gets very thick and fast
after that so in 1995 he was awarded the
santo police award for the best
relativist
under the age of 40. so he has you know
the
remarkable thing about him is research
papers
um research monographs and books like
scholarly books on quantum gravity
published by cambridge university press
quantum
covariance loop quantum gravity um
published in collaboration with
francesca vidoto in 2014
he writes research papers these
textbook type monographs detail
technical monographs
and fantastic global bestsellers
amongst which of course it's hard for me
to pick a favorite uh but the seven
brief lessons in physics
you know as someone who's written one
book myself i have to say
marvel it's been translated into 44
languages
and my favorite recent book has been uh
the order of time
um it's just absolutely fascinating so
he's of course as you can imagine
included uh by many
you know sort of the top thinkers of the
year by many magazines and on many many
lists so um suffice it to say that uh
today we have a speaker who is
amongst the list of hundred most
influential global thinkers we cannot
wait to hear from you carlo what you
have to teach
us about what is a cause
and why does it happen before the effect
and in hit good
characteristics style he asks a very
simple
question uh one that might seem obvious
to all of us
at least we have made that assumption
and he's going to be uh demystifying it
and
showing us the various layers so uh
without much further ado
carlo take it away and thank you so much
thank you for this extremely generous
and embarrassing presentation and
introduction
um i i'm very very honored uh
uh i'm very honored by the the opening
this series i hope to be at the level
i certainly will not be on the level of
what you're expecting me from this
introduction from this series
but i'll do my best um
let me share my uh screen
uh yes so as you just said
the exactly uh you you you gave the best
abstract of my talk
i'm asking a apparently naive question
what is a cause and why it happens
before the fact namely i'm talking about
causation
which is not about inference in general
of course is a
specific position seeing as causation in
nature
um this process causes this other
process
um and i'm questioning i'm asking about
the
the time ordering between the uh the
cause
and the effect the relation between um
uh uh
the the the arrow that goes from the uh
caused effect and the arrow does
goes from the uh from before in time to
after in time
it's an issue which has been which is
far from trivial as you will see as i
try to go into it
which has been uh puzzling for a long
time
and in fact is passing many physicists
as i will um i will uh argue
um and there's a lot of philosophy
around at
around at it and there are a lot of
different uh positions let me give you
let me start by giving you the bottom
line
um the rival point so to say
um there are two uh
sort of ideas about the
the source the origin of the time
orientation of causation
one is that it is in nature um
this little picture here with the
mountains
the moon and the stars is going to be my
icon for
uh uh furniture um
and uh it's primitive namely the way
nature work is that there's a past
there's a the past causes the present
the present causes the future
and so on so if we want to understand
nature that's the way it works there is
a direction of time which is the
direction
of events causing other events
the opposite view which
uh it's perhaps at first less uh obvious
but it's very obvious for
a person who studied theoretical physics
or physics in particular
it's just there's no error of time in
nature and the
relation between cause and effect has a
direction
um from one of the two uh
relata to the other which is just what
we project
on um
correlations which happen in nature
without any any time order so this this
little
uh person here is my uh icon for
uh we projecting on something and uh
what i want to argue is that my arrival
point
is that both these extreme views are
wrong in the sense that badly incomplete
and
what we have to do to understand the
the connection between position and and
direction of time
is to uh go into details and discover
that there is a very peculiar very
subtle dance
between the two the natural and the
subjective in a sense that it will try
to be
much clearer in in the course of this
which is far from obvious and which i
believe
science and physics in particular can
help
disentangle priya has used various times
the world disentangle i think it's a
proper world in this this kind of
context
we use idea we use notions so they are
made by various pieces
we should understand where they come
from this is a plan of what i'm going to
do
um the there is a
an original part which is the
intermediate one uh in which
i will uh present uh
a couple of results uh
that i obtained at the uh working on
physics especially in thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics in
in in recent years which i think
help adding one key
piece to the puzzle of understanding uh
causation
before getting there um i will spend
some times to
uh give an overview of views about
causation explaining why there is a
problem
what are the difference the different
perspectives that you find in the
literature from the classical literature
to the
current discussion about uh uh
position and i will argue first that
uh in science there is nothing like
time-oriented causes and then i will
argue for the opposite idea that in
science
there are in fact there are all over
time-oriented causes and i will
try to qualify in which sense uh both
statements are correct
once putting the the various pieces
together i
will conclude in in in the end by
trying to give the overall picture so
where the notion of causation comes in
why do we use it um what it is in in in
the way that we use it concretely in in
the sciences
and in our everyday life and i'll i'll
offer a tentative
sort of overall picture i will
also add at the end a little coda
uh about one further
step of understanding uh sort of one of
the
one of the layers of this construction
which is an idea of which i will be much
less
sure i can defend it uh all the way it's
an idea which i like but i'm
i'm far from from from um
from from certain about it so i i want
to distinguish it
a part in which i'm i'm i'm giving
uh a description of ideas which are
in the literature are a shorter part
which is my own contribution
a conclusion which i put all together
and then a part
in which unless unlikely the rest i am
less confident about everything all
right let me go into it and let me start
by say
what do we mean by causation and by
causation i mean what we usually mean by
position so everything at the opposite
everything we use the notion of cause
in our life in a variety of different
ways
when we talk about an event and we say
what is the cause of this event the
possible answer are
the most different ones right here is an
example
uh uh the door of my refrigerator is
closing now why because because i'm
pushing it
or all the possible ways of
thinking what the cause because i'm
picky because i was trouble
uh in my childhood by a very messy
mother so now i close all the doors
um in the scholarly literature uh
the different causes has been analyzed
since ever in all the centuries in all
the
geographies and uh i think
most people are more or less familiar at
least have heard
the analysis of the different causes
which are in aristotle
and um as as priya was mentioning
uh uh there is a a a a parallel very
often in indian thinking
uh to mediterranean thinking there is a
very uh parallel in fact slightly more
refined uh
version of the same breaking out of
position which is in aristotle
in buddhist in classical buddhist
philosophy now what i want to say is
that all this notion of causes
are time oriented including the final
causes of aristotle and
and and and and similar i don't want to
go
into the explicit discussion on in which
sense they are also time oriented if you
want you can ask a question about that
but the point is that in our use of the
notion of course there is also
a implicit assumption about the
direction of time
now what are causes how do we make sense
of of causes in the literature the
literature of
of philosophical equalization is vast
and there's all sort of
interpretations of what we mean by uh
causes
this is a list i'm not going to the list
i'm not uh
discussing uh them some of this idea
are going to appear in the in the in in
the later discussion
um i just mentioned the two extreme
position and the last line which is
primitivism
namely sort of a cause and effect are a
a fundamental notion we need to make
sense of nature and
what is going to happen so we shouldn't
uh break it up in something else
and to the opposite extreme elimination
we can get rid of it we just resolve it
in sense of
something else to understand nature we
don't need causes and effect
and you will see how this um this comes
in the in the discussion in a moment
and here i i address not the philosophy
of position i'm not a philosopher and in
fact
i put my hands ahead uh to the various
philosophers the audience
uh asking um pardon for my naivety
i will mention philosophical idea in a
naive way in which a physicist
like me uh sometimes related to them
um but i think um
philosophical naturalist i think
whatever we think philosophically i
i i talk to those who think like me that
should be informed by
the current science we have and science
has a lot to say about
position um uh right now
now why why where is the question why
there is a
an issue about uh time direction
because uh nature uh
very clearly and very surprising
uh has shown us that in its uh
fundamental laws
does not know about the time direction
this has come out from
from newton has been confirmed by all
the physics of the 18 19 20 21st
centuries all the fundamental physics we
have
uh tell us that the basic uh
laws uh that we see in the in in the
universe
don't distinguish uh past from uh from
future
um physicists tend to
interpret law uh i'll come back to that
uh just as irregularities in nature and
not as a sort of governing or pushing or
determining or anything like that
just as observation about regularity
nations and the regularities observed
uh our time reversal invariant um
let me explain just a few slides to make
this uh clear you often
talk you often hear physicists talk ab
talk about causation and offer often
mention equalization tools of the future
but if you look in the
in detail if you look at the books for
instance in in relativity uh
we say that if we know what happened at
some time in a space-time diagram this
is time this is space if there is a time
time slice in which we know what
happened
the the basic equations tell us that uh
from this knowledge we can infer what
happened in the causal
uh domain of dependence but if you look
carefully
this is also the causal domain of
inference in the past
not just in the future and whatever we
say to over the past is toward the
future
the same is true with light cones in in
special activity we say that an event if
i change in the sister of the world
would happen
in this point necessarily something
changes
but only in the future light corner but
if you
take physics seriously that's true it's
also true that it changes equally in the
past
light corner um there's nothing in
elementary physics that distinguish the
past and the future this is also true
about quantum mechanics
um the the the paper copied here is the
first paper who pointed this out
which is a little known but i'm very
attached to this paper is by a guy
known um called albert einstein in
uh 1931 um
this is also there's been a lot of
discussion i've also written about that
but uh uh just for the sake of this
discussion
just take the bottom line does quantum
mechanics
distinguishes the path from the future
the answer is no
quantum mechanics add a level of
uncertainty in our capacity of
predicting namely giving data in the
present we cannot determine the future
unique
universally but also the past given that
on the present we cannot determine the
past uh
universally this is the same uncertainty
so for a physicist
as i said physicists tend to have an
interpretation of laws just as
expressing regularities
um that's what you know you're talked
uh in the university department of
physics
laws don't govern don't compel don't
generally don't produce they just
describe observed irregularities which
are very very very strong and very
general of course
and this go lowe's a time reversal and
we do use a
language of causing for instance this is
a green ball which is not
moving the blue ball has a certain
velocity hits
the green ball and is the cause of the
motion
of the green ball after the event
but if you this is only the language
because in the physics the only thing
you have
is a given masses give a position a
relation
between the initial velocity v1 v2 and
the final velocity w1 w2
and this relation is expressed by a law
which goes in both
in in both equally in uh in both
directions so
if i if i play the actual motion ahead
in time
i can describe this as the blue ball
causing the motion of the green ball if
i play it back in time
i can cause it as the blue blue ball
causing the green ball to stop
and so the uh the cause and the effect
are a time reverse
depending of how i um i ran the the
time picture showing that if
it seemed to be saying all this that
what we call cause and we call it effect
are just the two terms or something
which is related by something
and just we use the name cause for the
one that come first and we use the name
um effect for the one that comes later
without any other
substantial difference between cause
effect except this one
um this is uh actually
uh um
let me give one more before before jump
into the next
uh the next point of discussion let me
give you one more uh sort of a
rhetorical example um this is a round
thing it's a bomb we use
uh the question of physics and you
compute that
uh you know if this is lighted after a
while is a big explosion and a big huge
cloud
this is another round thing so use the
equation of physics
and you connect it to another big cloud
okay except that this is a bomb
exploding this is the sun
being formed by the initial
uh dust cloud
that formed the solar system so actual
time
goes from the bomb to the explosion here
from the exploded thing to the sun
here once again
what causes what is not it could
does not seem to be a peculiarity of the
phenomenon by itself which one is a
cause which one is the first
it's just a fact of being ahead or later
in what we call the direction of time
now uh let me jump to the sort of
philosophical discussion about causes
and effect the physicists
of course uh there's a deep influence
from
the classics in particular hume famous
discuss
discussion about uh causation hume
is the uh is the first before uh
or or or or part of the very beginning
of the development of this uh
physicist way of thinking of the world
uh to
uh reduce the notion of causation to
just uh
happening together in fact in the
treaties he gives a
famous definition i'm not going to read
it read it in which he says
basically if you have something a and
something b that always happen together
we just uh this is what we mean by a
cosine b
and in this definition there's you can
reverse it uh
in time i mean if you uh the the only
distinction b
and b is that one is before that is
later nothing else
a little bit later in always in the
tweets he gives a second definition
the literature humors a lot of
discussion about the relation with
these two definitions i don't wanna go
at all
in which he talks about the uh idea that
forms in our mind
because of this uh repetition of having
observed
the uh the connection between a and b
because you you
um is more precise a and b are next to
one another
and then there's other things like a and
other things like b
things that resemble as interest and
will be that are the same relation
we observe this many times and says you
in our mind this gives the impression
that the two are necessarily related so
in the sense that the seeing the first
one give us
immediate video of the second and this
is even more
strong in the in the inquiry in which it
says custom
when does our experience useful to us
and makes us expect for the future
something that we observe
being connected so in these definitions
here it's
something that happened in our mind and
it is in our mind that the expectation
of the second um
it's uh it's what uh uh orient uh
the effect is what we're uh what we're
expecting
while the cause is what we're aware of
so this is oriented disoriented
while in nature is not um
i could go more in detail but i think
i'm i'm giving you the
the gist of that and if you you know a
few centuries go by
and uh things are not changed very much
if you take
a a a a a recent philosopher
this is uh david lewis the the the the
most cited of the recent philosophers in
the in the stanford encyclopedia
he gives a definition of causation which
i'm not gonna
read and go into the details also
because it's not very good it has been
much
criticized i don't want to go in the
details
but it's essentially young one made much
more precise
with probability instead of
just many times happening together and
with the two
the causes effect not necessarily being
contiguous to one another because it
could be a chain
between one and another um and uh
but but if you really carefully uh the
the calls happen at time t
the effect at the time t prime but
there's nothing that says which is which
unless the fact that we just uh assume
that t is before t
prime and therefore we call cause the
one that comes first
all this goes into the direction that
in nature causes the notion of causation
uh play doesn't play any role the only
thing that plays a role in nature
is regularities between phenomenon that
can be described
by physical laws or by other laws in in
other sciences
and this is a position which is
widespread among physicists
and at some point was a prominent in in
philosophy
and famously nobody put it more uh
clearly and strongly than burton russell
in a uh influential paper he wrote in
1913 about causation or causes
in which there is this uh celebrated
sentence that says the law of causality
i believe
uh like much of that passes monsters
among philosophers
um sorry to the philosopher listening
but russell was obviously a philosopher
is a relic of a bygone age surviving
like the monarchy
british of course only because it is
erroneously supposed to do
no harm so if you want to understand it
you forget about causes
it's just mythology right natural things
happen and they're related by laws
there's nothing that causes anything
this is just our language
that projects something funny on on on
nature
good now let me add our
argue in the opposite direction right
now
because as it has been observed uh
repeatedly
um we use causes and uh all together and
when priya
um introduced the the
the the the this discussion at some
point she said
um the the the grand picture of the laws
of physics that describe
you know causes and an effect in the
universe priya is obviously a scientist
he's an astrophysicist always deep
immersed in the
the scientific way of thinking she
naturally used the world causes an
effect
and in fact causes the fact that patches
russell are all over science
we talk about causes and effect all the
time right
it seems that what we're interested in
finds is causes
isn't that what we ask all the time what
causes this
why uh what what is the effect causes uh
produced by this cause not only that but
in all the applied science we're
interested in causes right we want to
know whether the taking the vaccine
causes
a diminishing in the number of people
dying or getting
uh getting ill so how do we put these
things together
there is no oriented causation
there's nothing oriented in fundamental
science
um i take a sort of physicist uh uh
position in which whatever happens to be
in some physics
um everything where interest about the
world is
uh causes perceived effect and there is
no orientation in nature
something goes wrong here there's a
there's a contradiction between these
different assumptions
and nobody put this uh strongly and
clearly like nancy cartridge
who um has uh uh violently attacked
uh in fact the uh russell idea that uh
uh
causation plays no role in science
arguing that science is all about
uh causal explanations and uh
she has a book whose title is uh hunting
causes
etc and um that in fact this is what
we're interested in
so the theoretical explanation in the
sense the kind of inspiration that
russell was
had in mind when he was he wrote these
phrases
uh that's not science in a sense for for
for a chiropractor because cow's
explanation
in her world had have some truth into
them and i disagree with this in a
number of things
one is her emphasis in the disunity of
science
i think is is is either attacking a
straw man
uh making too much of unity or not
seeing what has happened in the last
century which is a spectacular
uh uh harmony and the disappearance of
all the apparent
um contradiction between different
sciences
and even more i disagree with her that's
central to what i'm saying together
today to her conclusion that precisely
because in theoretical physics causes
are absent but are crucial to our
understanding of the world
precisely for that theoretical physics
is incomplete
i think this is just either naive or
wrong depending in which sense you take
it but she's completely right she's
obviously completely right
that the ubiquity of a notion of cause
in science
it's uh it's uh it's all over now how do
we
sort out come out of this uh confusion
well if you just look for a little bit
of clarity
it's not so hard after all because
obviously eliminative is in foundations
which was
what russell was talking about does not
mean that we drop an ocean
it only means that we do not trace this
notion
to the foundation we trace it to
something else that can be contingent
particular
and can be very vastly a very vast
application
but not for this it has to be thrown
away like the monarchy
right only because uh you know in
fundamental
physics you never talk about cats
that doesn't mean that there are no cats
that cats is a bad idea
that we should forget about cats cats
are cats their
world is full of cats we can have
science about cats cats are great
even if they're not a part of
fundamental physics so the fact that
causation cannot be read into
fundamental physics
there's no reason for it to mean that we
should eliminate from science
or that we make a mistake when we're
using science uh i think that there is a
there is a a clean position that
uh uh allows us to think that position
is uh it's ubiquitous we use it over
or everywhere but it's not in the
fundamental elementary laws of physics
there are plenty of things which are not
in the fundamentals of physics like cats
like the internet like like the sun
um but nevertheless you know supervising
an appropriate situation to the
fundamental laws of physics
um but let's open a question so
what do we trace causation to and here i
want to mention
a recent development which had
had a lot of influence both in
applications and on philosophical
thinking about
causation which is mathematical modeling
of causes
itself it's called causal modeling has
been developed by a number of
people uh judea perl was one of the most
influential he has a
very influential books on the on the on
the argument
in which he gives a picture um an
extraordinary good picture of how do we
use causes and what
we mean when we use position and i think
this is the
good entry point to separate the
uh elemental physics but there's no
causation
from where and try to tell us where
position come in in the description of
the world
so in in great summary this causal
modeling function like that
in the in the universe you have a lot of
variables that describe what happened
but you select a smaller number of
variables say s t
x y w z so some some may say
that the number of people in the country
the number of people who get the covered
those who are get the vaccine those who
get to the hospital
those et cetera et cetera et cetera and
then you
know you assume you know some relations
between these this relation can be i
either um because you know the law
that connect them some physical laws
some
some some scientific laws or because you
have made some data
you have a large number of data so you
can do some frequency you can interpret
frequency probability so you have a
probability distribution
over the values of the uh
these variables of assignment of
variables
values to this to these variables okay
from there you uh
deduce a causal relations
as follows first of all you time
all these variables so these variables
take value at some time
and you fix the time ordering of this
so this s comes before t and so on and
and before w and so on
um this is an input
and another input is that you assume
that all the direction of position are
toward the future
and this is crucial so it's an
assumption that causation is toward the
future
and then from the probabilities or from
the laws
you deduce where you should put an arrow
by using the notion of intervention and
the notion of intervention is defined in
the next slide
it's as follow interventions is
something that
can happen you can do on the data on a
certain variable
by doing the following thing
disregarding the relation between
anything that comes earlier in time
and looking according to the
probabilities according to the law that
you know
what changes in the future if you change
this variable so for instance why
change in w does not change if you
double in the future then there is no
arrow between t and w
and then you say that t causes a a
variation in t causes variation y
variation y equals variation z
and and and so on and pill has a theorem
in fact that it's in the bottom of the
slide here
if the variables are time indexes so you
have to time index a variable first if
you if you take some
some technical steps then the
probability distribution fixes the graph
so it tells you what is the cause of
what for instance it tells you that
uh i don't know the the the the fact of
uh having the vaccine by itself doesn't
change the probability
of getting close to somebody who has a
uh
a a they covet but the fact of taking
the vaccine diminish the probability of
getting the call with the tone and so on
so forth
so this capture the uh the way we use
causes
in concrete and uh i mean there's been a
debate between pale and cartridge if
this is really capture all possible
causation
nancy cartridge says no but i think this
is a
finer details she she was she want a
larger
notion of what we mean by by acquisition
i think this is extremely wild
wide because uh it does capture
um in science uh everything
that we describe as this variable t
affect this variable uh y uh
change in the variable t is a cause of
change in variable y
and this re uses the notion
of intervention so there's something
intervening
on the variable t and the first thing
you can think is that there's a human
being here doing something a variable t
this is not in contradiction with
existence of laws because remember
this is a subset of the variable of the
universe so this could be us in
in the universe which you have
disregarded the laws you had
is at fixed value of everything else but
if in
everything else something is not fixed
have changed for instance a human doing
something
um then you can break the laws
that you started from that connected
these variables among themselves
and once you understand that you
understand that this manipulation the
intervention does not need to be a human
it can be anything and you can go to a
more general notion of agency
um much wider than a human by agency
meaning
any thing any phenomenon that acts on t
careful and was not included in the
set of flows that you had between these
variables here for instance uh
a meteorite falling from the sky and and
and and breaking something this is a
this is an agent
because it's uh it's i i have a
description of what happened
under certain condition something
outside this condition
something external um comes in this is
an intervention
uh by an agent that's what i mean by
agency which is not necessarily
uh human so what is agency it's a
breaking of
past causal links past causal links
which is possible in a approximate
description
which did include something so something
else can uh
can come in okay
position and i think this is the bottom
line of this long discussion
makes sense if there is intervention and
if this
agency and it's precisely something in
the
time orientation of agency which haven't
got to it yet
that gives the time orientation of
position so
if there's nothing if we don't have an
approximate description
broken by an external agent and if you
don't think
that the passive fixer that is the
future that is going to be affected
there is no way of reducing causation to
something understandable
in physical terms but everything every
time you use causation
in a way in science which is
understandable in terms of
time there is a a set of relation which
is approximate
something coming out from this relation
breaking the
the approximation some exogenous agent
and an assumption that the past remain
the same and the future changes
good let me go to the second part
and the key part of the talk now we have
understood what is the role of the agent
and
for the moment let me think is a human
and it can be also stone
falling from the sky a key point
is that whatever is the agent where
there is a stone falling from the sky or
with a human
or a machine whatever it's still a part
of nature
it's not outside nature right
because i'm a naturalist i don't believe
that the things outside nature
so i should be able to understand the
agent which
intervenes and allows us to think in
terms of causes
why it how it works
how we can keep the past fixed and
affect the future
and that's where i want to bring in
two key pieces of the puzzle which i
think glue the thing
together namely the physics of the agent
and why the actual physics we have
which is time reversal environment
fundamentally nevertheless
allows the time orientation of the two
key characteristics
of the this way of thinking which is
that the idea that the past is fixed and
the future is open
well let me discuss these two um these
two uh
points here separately
what makes the past fixed remember the
the
the agent intervenes but does not change
the the past
only changes the future and second how
can it change the future
now first the past the fact that the
past is fixed is a common experience of
all of us
because the present is
plenty of traces of the past
with each picture of the past we have
memories of the past
there are craters on the moon that
witness for you know stones falling
on the moon in the past not in the
future with steps on the sun and so on
and so forth
is this in contradiction with
what i've been preaching for the first
first 10 minutes that
fundamental physics time reversal
environment
no of course because is a microphysics
which is time reversal environment
is the laws connecting
a domain of variables when you don't
disregard anything else
but the macrophysics of the world is
obviously time-oriented
right the phenomena that we witness
every day
are irreversible so the macrophysics
is irreversible and we know why it is
irreversible
because the fundamental overtime
reversal invariant
but when you have a course grading
microscopic description
this determines an entropy and
the individual solutions of the equation
of motion that don't need to be time
symmetric so the the the behavior
of the macroscopic um variable
can be uh known uh can be
irreversible if the entropy was low in
some
in in one of the direction of time the
one we call the past
so the world is time oriented but
microscopically
not microscopically and for a long time
i've tried directly to connect
the thermodynamical macroscopic time
orientation of the world irreversibility
with the notion of agency with the
notion of causation with the notion of
um
fixity of the past and an opening of the
future
and i couldn't because i think
the key step which is needed is
understand what are traces
and in which sense agent um open up the
future
so let me go into that uh since
traces of microscopic phenomena and
since they're time oriented they can
only tell me oriented because
microphysics is time-oriented microfiche
is time oriented because of second law
of thermodynamics
so there should be a way of
understanding how the second law of
thermodynamic leads to traces
and it's possible to show i'm not going
into the physics
into the details uh but let me give you
the the
the the statement here which is um uh
shown in a
in a paper a few years ago of mine if
you have a thermodynamical system
which is uh composed by um
a weakly interacting subsystem so if
there's a segregation of subsystem
and they interact weakly so it doesn't
go directly to equilibrium
which is the normal situation of a
universe if initially is out of
equilibrium
which is the situation of our universe
and if the thermalization times are long
so again if if each individual
component takes a lot of time to
equilibrate
then you can show that completely
generically there are microscopic traces
namely there are microscopic
configuration of the variables that
uh from which you can deduce event in
the past
and not in the future not going to the
i've prepared some
little model showing in a in in a super
simplified way how this happened i'm not
going
uh into it and i'm not going into the
thermodynamics
of the of the story um because you know
the audience is fast i want just to give
the
the main idea the main idea is that
precisely because you start at low
entropy um
as time goes on entropy grows so you you
you you just lose information in the in
the growth of entropy but part of this
information is captured
and you can see it concretely in
mechanical models into the traces
so a memory has information about
something about an event you can measure
how much is this information okay
and the way this information come from
from the increasing entropy of
decreasing negative entropy uh that
happen along the terminalization so
memory is a physical mechanism
uh which can be cleanly understood
in terms of standard statistical
mechanics and thermodynamics
that are some low entropy into
information
okay
agency once this is understood agency is
relatively simple
because what is an agent again is a
system it's a physical system so the
base laws of nature
um such that it can
take the same macroscopic past and split
it in different microscopic futures
okay since it is time oriented
we are time-oriented necessarily it's
microscopic
namely uh what we call by agent is a
microscopic description
of a um a system
and being microscopic it's time oriented
by the second law of turnover now
because it's an environment flow entropy
the entropy
uh the enterprise so agency is an
incomplete description
and notice that this matches exactly
with the causal modeling
uh uh description what is the agency
at the basis of the notion of causality
so it's an incomplete description
um let me jump to the
uh to the to the picture here
um if you have a macroscopic history of
the world
and a a a moment of time in which an
agent can split between different
macroscopic
evolutions you're not contradicting
the determinism of the microphysics
because a macroscopic
history is a large number of possible
microphysics
one going up one going straight and one
going down
so um an agent is simply
a system such that it has a dynamic
which we disregard in gram part which
is not an agent anymore when we open it
up
and and see what it is that determines
um
uh according to which microstate was
the system uh the macro state before
which one
of the future uh happens
so it's it's something that decides
whether going this way
or of this way and this is not only
permitted by uh elementary physics
but it's exactly what happened and once
again
um i i uh the same model as before
shows it's exactly what happened if
the three condition i go back to the
three conditions i had before
are satisfied namely uh you need a
global system composed by a subsystem
you need an initial thermodynamic at
equilibrium
and long term realization times
automatically
um the uh uh you get
you get agency let me give you a sketch
in this super simple model
of what is going on here you have two
systems a system with many little balls
which should
describe thermodynamically statistically
so you don't know the
the velocity of this ball and then you
have a some macroscopic pendulum
moving and if the interaction are very
rare
once in a while one of the little balls
hit a big pendulum so the big pendulum
oscillates
okay if the initial distribution of
energy
is not in equilibrium between the two
what happens is that
uh generically energy goes from the
little balls to the big balls
so when you see one ball oscillating
this is a memory
of a previous hit a previous exchange of
energy between the two systems
okay but also you can view the
the red system as a system you don't
know what's going on
but at some point it chooses to hit one
or the other
of these balls so this is a minimal
modeling of a system that
chooses and of course this is uh nothing
all
that uh reading the classical reading
of uh um agency which you find for
instance espinoza
when famously espinoza sings writes men
think themselves free
because they're conscious of their
choices and their desire but they are
ignorant of causes that incline them
to want and choose and this never gives
the faintest talked
even in their dreams to those causes
this is not to say that men do not
choose they choose that's exactly what
they do
but by saying they choose what we mean
is that we're giving a microscopic
description of what goes on
in which the internal what humans are
the brain of the body uh splits the
the macroscopic evolution of the of the
future
so memory and agency are physical
mechanisms that transform law entropy
into
information and by the way i think this
is the ultimate source of the
information on which biology and culture
build at large and now we can bring
everything together i'm doing with time
good
i'm getting to the to the end i'll skip
this i'll come back maybe
in a moment of that um
the past is fixed because of traces the
future is open
because uh the same macro paths can
evolve into different macro future these
are facts
these are facts which are uh generated
thermodynamically
by a microscopic description of system
which is out of equilibrium
the system segregation and
thermalization
so therefore
the origin of
the direction of causation
is in the asymmetry of agency
which acts at some point
influencing the future and the presence
of traces that allows us to consider the
past fixed they
to know about the past okay so it is
because we are
agent that have memory of the past
and can split the future that
that we have the possibility of
intervening in the sense of the causal
modeling
the direction of time it's in nature is
in the second law of thermodynamics
is not in us it's not we're not
projecting something magic in our
we are governed by the second law of
thermodynamics
which permits existence of traces so
nature has a direction of time
in its macroscopical description
so nature is macroscopically
uh time-oriented and microscopically
non-time-oriented
this macroscopical uh orientation
of the reversible phenomena so all
microscopic phenomena
give rise to traces and to our
possibility to split
in the future and in turn we use this
to read the causal relation
between incomplete descriptions of
nature
in causal terms so this
is the full uh picture
uh and you see it's a funny dance
between uh subjective and objective
between uh
special and and general there's no
time orientation in the fundamental laws
we never describe all the degrees of
freedom we describe macrophysics
it is a contingent fact not imposed by
though but
allowed by the law that this microscopic
description
has passed law entropy therefore we are
immersed in a world which is uh
full of reversible phenomena time
oriented
these irreversible phenomena permit the
assistance of traces
so because of that the past looks so
fixed
the knowledge present give us a huge
amount of knowledge of the past
and little knowledge of the future much
less knowledge of the future
and also precisely the same uh
second of the dynamics allows certain
physical system macroscopically
to determine different microscopic
future for the same microscopic paths of
their agents and this is what we are
so we are agent that can split the
future and consider the past fixed
and therefore we have a notion of
manipulativity we can do that
i can give the vaccine to people and
therefore people will
will heal okay and because we have this
uh
strongly time-oriented notion of
intervention
we think in terms of position which is
what interests us because after all what
i want to know
is what would happen if i do this and
that and this is the
overall picture now
that's my rival point let me make two
two final comments before uh
before concluding if i have a couple of
minutes
uh more one i've skipped
one uh consideration here this is a
little bit of a
side consideration but you're you're in
terms of inference in general and i can
i think i should not
avoid mentioning this uh
at the light of everything i said uh
this is something always fascinated me
uh
inference implications is in pure logic
of course
and by itself has nothing to do with uh
time
right if you say on humans a mortal
socket is a human
human and therefore socrates is mortal
this is not after time this isn't after
that in time logic is outside time if i
say little a's in the set a and
set a is the sub so b therefore a little
uh
set b this is not after so this leaves
outside time but nevertheless we use a
temporal
language for talking about logical
implications
why do we there's something funny here
we use a temporal language because in
our thinking
we walk through the logical
a temporal world in time and of course
if you want to
um think about the consequence of some
premises
we have to hold the premises in our
memory
and we can only remember the past we
cannot remember the future
so there is a very peculiar you see
there is a very peculiar
game here it's not what i was talking
about because i was talking about
causation in physical world this is not
about the physical world
but there is something remarkably
similar in the relation between that a
temporal world the logic
and the the way our own thinking
uh deals with uh
if you want to believe there is a
temporal world of of logic which is
always in time
but why it is in time because of
specific specific physics of our brain
which works things to remember the past
thanks to traces and being open you know
when we
um we write premises it's like we don't
yet know what is the possible
uh uh the possible uh conclusion the
possible thesis
and so this is one is the correct one
among
others so once again i think it's very
important to disentangle
the kind of relations which don't depend
on the peculiar orientation in time of
our way of thinking because of
what we are as a macroscopic physical
being in the second law of
thermodynamics
um from the one that depend
uh depend on that now this
the the the last comment um
has to do with this microscopic
approximation here
so if you notice there is i left a hole
here
and this is an idea which uh
i want to mention to just to complete
this this picture here
it's perfectly okay to say that the
macro variables are whatever they are
and the fact that entropy was low in the
past is just a contingent fact of nature
or as david albert want to say it's also
law of nature let's call it the law of
nature
and then we have a law saying that the
past is special
but there's another possibility which i
find far more
interesting which is the following when
we say that entropy was low in the past
we should remember what entropy is
entropy depends on two things the state
of the universe and
the microscopic variables that we use
now the macroscopic variables are not
arbitrarily chosen
they are determined by the physical
interaction
between a system and another system so
if s is a universe and o is a subset
all interact with s through not all the
variables the units but to a finite
number of variables a 1
a n and the entropy is a number of
microstate
corresponding to given values of this
finite number of variables so in other
words
the microscopic variables are determined
by the
system with respect to which entropy is
defined it's wrong to say
that the system by itself has an entropy
a system
has an entropy only if you say with
respect to which system is interacting
or
with respect to which variable your your
your measuring design to be
but this opens an obvious possibility
that if the state
the entropy universe was low in the past
it's not the state that was special
is the subsystem that determines special
microscopic variables
so low entropy may mean not there is
something non-generic
in the microstate of the universe but
there's something non-generic
in the subsystem with respect to which
from the perspective of which you're
looking at the universe
and the second possibility makes much
more sense to me
and if so and this is my last slide
the macroscopic approximation
from which the very orientation of time
the second law of thermodynamics
is determined is also perspectival
is not subjective in the sense that is
arbitrary in any sense it's perspectival
in the same sense in which
the rotation of the sky that we see
around us is perspective
it's not a subjective effect it's true
the sun rotate
is a sun sunset and sunrise
um but we don't understand it by looking
at the sky at the stars of the moon
we understand and look looking at the
relation between
you know the stone on which rotating on
which we sit and and the rest of the
universe
so i think that also the uh the second
auto dynamic should be understood in a
similar way
namely a simulation of a set of
variables in terms of which we exist
as a microscopic object
which are special and especially in the
sense that with respect to those
um the you the entropy of the universe
was was the past and why they're special
well because
otherwise they we wouldn't have been i
mean we are
being in time that's what we are biology
is a process in time that can only
happen
in a set of macroscopic variables with
respect to which there is a single law
of thermodynamics
and therefore can only happen in a
subset of microscopic variables
which has a property of being uh related
to the rest of the universe
in a way that the term is a low entropy
so i'll put a question mark here because
this is a
idea which i'm fascinating but i'm um
it's bald and courageous the rest i'm a
much
uh so you can bracket that the rest i'm
i'm i'm i'm ready to defend against
against
uh uh against criticism of course if
things are strong enough i'll change my
mind
so bracketing that position is time
oriented
definitely why because
when we talk about position we are
always talking about intervention
so if i do that or if something does
that
something happened in the past and the
notion intervention requires
something exogenous something external
so we are talking about a certain
phenomena
which we understand by themselves but we
also assume that something can happen
from the outside
and we assume that whatever the
situation
we know what was in the past and we
don't know what is the future
and why we make this assumption not
because we are you know
uh time oriented natural beings
but because we are macroscopic phenomena
in a macroscopic time-oriented uh
description of the universe and it can
be shown that the
the the second-order analysis generates
existence of
traces allows the um the existence of
of uh um agency but importantly
is not the second law of the dynamics
does nothing to do with causation by
itself
at all if anything second law of
thermodynamics destroys information
doesn't produce it
doesn't allow to predict anything allows
us to to lose information
um what the second law of thermodynamics
plus system segregation plus load
terminalization times
allows to is traces an agency and this
is the basis that generates our very
peculiar description of the world
in terms of intervention which ground
the notion of causation
so causality is not in nature by itself
it's not a fundamental way for
understanding nature
but is an ubiquitous extraordinary
uh general way we have as agent
for interacting with approximate
description of the world
where we actually can act in some moment
knowing the past and having the future
open
and this is it thank you very much
thank you so much carlo that was um
really really amazing so i'm going to
request request everyone to clap
virtually
to express our thanks uh this was a
brilliant dissection
of uh cause and effect and um i'm
particularly
um uh interested in how nicely you
clarified this
role of the second law of thermodynamics
which is often
like really invoked uh to account
for the existence of an arrow of time
itself
and i think you kind of very nicely
clarified why
it is that you arrive at the notion of
an
arrow and that has a lot more to do with
the tracers
than it does with the actual content of
the law
or the predictions of the law so before
i open up to questions
um i wanted to ask a sort of a
quick quick question myself
um and that really has to do
i mean it is this sort of um deeper
question
about do you think it is our
own sense of biological
time and the degeneration
that goes with it there's a degeneration
and a lifetime that goes with it
so that has a fundamental impact
and i think you discussed this briefly
in your book right in order of time
that this sort of rhythms are set
by these very very um
random uh random events right so
um and therefore if we had been sentient
beings
with no lifetime at all
then uh you know the way in which you
would order
things uh might look completely
different right i mean
yes i do i do i i definitely do think so
um the the the
somehow the overall idea behind the book
the
the the audio of time is that a lot of
confusion we make about the notion of
time
because we are mixing up different
notions we are missing our different
levels of what time is
um as you as you said opening the series
we need to disentangle and we get
clarity by disentangling
so we tend to say time is this time is
that
but time is a lot of things and there is
an experimental time there's a
psychological time
there is a time of the clock uh there is
a
time variable in generativity these are
all somehow related to one another well
obviously
but they're very different layers so
when you you you mentioned the sense of
the
you know the uh you said the biological
and the degeneracy
of the time this what we perceive
experientially of the passing of time
it has to do not with directly with a
clock time
because that's not what we are we our
perception is something much more
complicated
we're perceiving well more complex layer
of phenomenons
um one silly way of
of putting this is that uh
we remember time because we know time
because we remember a moment ago
and a clock doesn't remember a moment
ago right clock has no memory
so clock doesn't have the same sense of
time of us obviously even if it had a
sense it could
he so we should we should take apart the
various pieces of time
um and when we say this aspect of time
comes because of
the way our brain works it does not mean
that okay so this is what time is
nothing else because a clock is still a
clock and measure a variable that we can
legitimately call time
just we shouldn't use the same word
so cavaliering without realizing that it
means different things
right and you know and as you mentioned
a lot of this wanting to
order cause and effect in time has to do
with the need to make predictions right
to for uh you know probabilities or
uh of occurrence of future
events yes um
and uh exactly it has to do with with a
needle making predictions
qualified because there is a sense
in which we can make prediction equally
toward the future toward the past right
we
figure out the solar system dynamics so
system is a very
controllable system it's an almost
perfect physical dynamical system which
um and so we can measure the position of
velocity you know
venus mars jupiter everything and make
great prediction
to the future and to the past equally
there's no there's no difference
in a sense right this is where i was
gonna
just interject the word i mean
determinism right the fact that it's a
deterministic system
without chaos and uncertainty that
is exactly right into it right okay
exactly exactly
and to the extent in which there is
uncertainty okay
and to the extents in which we have a
system which is open to
to to to external uh to external uh
something else we have also different
kind of questioning which is not just uh
we and the other question is what
happened if
okay and i can also ask it for the solar
system no
what happened if a meteorite come in
and that's also i can do in the past and
in the future for instance
uh suppose a computer was a a a an
eclipses
at the time of a battle of uh you know
uh between uh uh the mabarata between
the pandava
and the and the mentioned eclipses that
i want to compute where it was
and then somebody says well wait a
minute what happened if in between
there was an asteroid going by and the
moon has a little bit accelerated
so what happens if it can work in the
pasture in the future
but we are interested in a very specific
what happened if
what happened if i do something and i
know the past right
and that's what that's what causation is
right
position is if i if i say hi
what are you going to answer okay i know
i remember what happened before but i i
can
interject something here i want to know
what happened in the future and that's
when causation comes
in and we're using this logic to
understand nature
it's powerful logic but it's a sort of
high-level logic it's not a
low-level logic in the way nature works
and that
that we we need to make all these
discriminations about the system
the subsystem uh about um
also um you know which
part of the the past is
fixed you take the past is fixed
then you know it's a dynamic view versus
a passive view of the past
right so you can have both a dynamic and
a passive view of
of the past and that depends on the
system and the subsystem
in question but okay so i will not
hog you and i will ask the first
question uh
peter morgan who actually works on the
nature of quantum mechanics
here at yale so his question was without
disagreeing with much of what you've
said carlo the past is only fixed in so
far
as traces persist is it only that the
creation of traces is relatively
fast and the decay of traces is slower
if we burn the evidence it is gone
um yes my answer is yes
and
to me it has been a long
uh path to accept this thing this idea
but i am pretty convinced now so there
is nothing else
that makes the past fixed
beside the fact the natural fact that
because of the second law of
thermodynamics
we have a huge amount of traces of the
past microscopic traces of the past
so we have a great amount of information
about the past we don't have about the
future
i don't think there is any anything else
and uh um uh
peter works in in quantum mechanics is a
it's a long and subtle discussion
um how this uh
plays off in quantum theory because the
usual presentation of quantum theory and
textbook
is i make a preparation and then i make
a measurement in the future
so it seems to be a narrow time seems to
be in
the textbook representation of the
theory but i think this is just a
presentation thing
um i could uh you know i could i could
make a save measurement and then i can
ask if i know this what do i know about
the previous and the past one
and and so i think it would be the same
in in in quantum mechanics so the
the the the that the way he
put it in i just read in the chat uh i i
would stand with it it's
it's existence of traces that give us
the fixit of the past and the existence
of traces
is rooted in the second law of
thermodynamics which in turn is rooted
in pascal entropy
so the next question is from sean sunder
who is a faculty in the school of
management
and his question is if the nat if nature
could be partitioned into one micro and
one macro layer
then no direction at micro and direction
at macro argument simply would not work
but if nature consists of an arbitrary
number of layers in micro
and macro state hierarchies then this
reversal between adjacent layers of
hierarchy would not work
how would it work in three or more
layers if it
how would it work yeah
yeah i was reading through so it would
it says it would work if it is in two
what about if it is in more um
uh i take note and i'll think about
i i don't think i can answer immediately
but it might be i don't know if this is
a question that has a
an obviously immediate answer or not
maybe not i think i need i need to think
about that
okay there's a question from rohit
parikh who's asking if two people
observing the same
traces make different inferences about
the past
we assume that one is right and the
other is wrong or both are wrong
but perhaps there is no fact of the
matter as to how the past was
then the past just like the future is a
fan of possibilities
i'm not suggesting this but pointing it
out as one way to look at things
i think this is sort of what i was
alluding to as well about dynamic
past versus passive past
yes uh and there's something
disconcerting in that
i think the the the the actual answer
depend
whether you fold quantum mechanics in or
not
so if if bar was zero if the world was
not
quantum mechanical we could make a
a fantasy story sort of forgetting
excessive
uh chaos and say well
the the history of the world is eighth
of the world period
uh but then it will be equal to the
future
i mean it's just one easter of the world
is the past in the future
um but we know that there is
uh at least what we have access to the
world is probabilistic because of
quantum mechanics
and chaos and everything else uh
and this is what uh
definitely makes the future open but i
believe
strongly that um it equally
makes the past open so the past is
undetermined
and what we mean by the determination of
the past
precisely the existence of traces so
microscopically is the terminal i mean
we have a
you know i can take a movie and then
later on i look at the movie and say
look
this is a hard proof of what happened
but microscopically i cannot do this
quantum mechanically
so the next question is from nicholas
gaul
so is the concept of agency and the
derivative concept of causation
merely a form of stance in the sense of
stance described by
dennett example an agential stance
is a stance like intentional stance
all such stances merely give us more
fruitful explanatory and predictive
power
even more generally albert's past
hypothesis
of low entropy is also another stance
one that is fruitful for our macroscopic
purposes
um
i don't know i don't know it's it's a
deep question i
i tend to answer no
i mean tend to answer um
but i but i'm not pretty sure
my first reaction i should copy all
these chats and think about
them later my immediate reaction would
be to
say uh that
no we actually um
us subsystem uh i mean since we just
de facto interact with the world through
some variables they factor we have a
macroscopic
description so the fact that there are
uh their traces so the fact that is
there is agency
so it's just a description of what is
going on
so causation ultimately is a description
of what is going on
but not at the fundamental level after
it's like you know it's a description of
what is going on
that in my car if i push the accelerator
it goes faster there's nothing
fundamental here it's a story about
the what actually but it's not a stance
it's just
you know what it is it seemed
it seems to me that this is the case but
i might be
wrong here and maybe it's just a
choice of a perspective so um
so i'll i'll think more carefully about
this question
so um the next question is from uh
computer scientists and philosopher
brian cantwell smith
uh who is part of our series and we'll
be speaking um
later on uh he asks i hear you saying
that biology and culture required low
entropy macroscopic variables
so that is how why where we developed
could it be instead
could it instead be that we are more
responsible for the low entropy
macroscopic properties we use
rather than as a consequence of them for
example could it be that we human
coarse grain the world in ways that
parcel it up
in low entropy ways and restrict the
ways in which we find it intelligible
including i would say establishing
object identity
to those that allow us to think and
imagine
um great question i would not think that
the two alternatives are alternatives
i think i i i i it seemed to me that
the second is
very likely a convincing story of what
happens in our
relation with the world and is not
alternative to the first
because to um to play out the second
we need a lot of previous information to
start with
uh and so what what i was talking about
is not um when i said i mean he he
um he i forgot his name
ryan cantwell smith orion thank you ray
um
i'm happy he picked up this uh for me
it's a it's
it's it's it's it's an idea that hit me
very strongly
uh biology worked with information and
and and culture works with information
where does information come
come from in a sense there's a sense in
which you cannot create information from
nothing in some sense
uh where does it come from and and if it
is true
i mean agency create information right i
decided to go right or left
so there was no bit now there's one bit
information i've gone right
left and and traces that information i
mean i
i picture give me information about the
past in in all possible senses of
information
where does it come from from the
perspective of a physicist
so for a family of physicists imagine
the world is just little stone bouncing
around
where is information or or a quantum
state or whatever
it's not in the microphysics is in the
macrophysics
and is sourced by the negative entropy
to start from
okay so this is what gives the raw
material
of inflation that's what biology can
work with culture can work with but then
the way we deal with information is
extraordinarily complicated complex it's
certainly not just making
memories and and making choices we do
all sort of stuff with information right
we talk think write books do computers
and everything
and the way we then interact with the
world to capture other information
is very complex and i'm certainly i'm a
physicist i'm not
at all uh going into this complexity
and the fact that we are actively um
filtering out um trains saying
it it's a it it's it it's a perspective
that seems very credible to me and i
don't see in contradiction with
what my sort of the the the underlying
generation of raw information from from
from past low entropy great
um so we have a question from jenny
wagner
is the definition of entropy in the
second law of thermodynamics unique
could there possibly be a definition of
entropy which was high in the past
yes um i think it's as it's not unique
and i think there could be a definition
of entropy that
was high in the past and uh um
i have a uh let me give you a
uh two little examples one is is
actually from physics i mean
if i take the the the air in this room
i say well it's just some molecules and
the pressure and a volume
temperature and emphasis i can write
down i know the volume of the pressure i
can compute the entropy here's it
it's a number jowl or whatever
but now say oh wait a minute i also have
i i also
can measure not only that i have a
thermometer and
and the pressure meter and the meter for
the volume i also have a device that
computes the relative
amount of oxygen and and and nitrogen
okay so i can measure that so
now i have one more device so now i have
to redo the calculation of enthalpy
it's a different entropy it's slower
so entropy depends of how interact and
can it be
higher in the past and longer path yes
um here is an example
i either box with some balls bouncing
around
okay i think a movie and the the balls
are in some position
and then some end of time and then they
move in some other position some end of
time
and you look at them and you say well i
don't know the entropy seem to be the
same on both
but i said oh no sorry i showed you the
movie with a filter
let me take away the filter and you see
that originally all the yellow movie
were
one side or the blue one the other side
one end of time so they mix it up they
say oh i can do an easy entropy
calculation you know
my macroscopic thing how many yellow are
on the left and clearly the entropy went
up
because it will mix it and then say
wait wait wait there's another filter in
fact
and the other filter shows that in fact
not only the the the the the
the balls were yellow and blue but they
also were you know some with a little
bump and some with a little
some other properties and in fact you do
a calculation of this property and you
define
that the entry was lower than the other
side
so you can make it up stories in which
entropy
can be one direction that direction
depending
on the microscopic variable that you use
which depending on how you look at them
so depending on your own interaction
with them so it's not subjective it
depends on the actual
interaction hamiltonian between the
system and the other system the physical
system with respect to which entropy is
defined
great so um we have the final two
questions
um so we have uh dashia who is asking
what is your interpretation of retro
causality
which is used in very context was used
in in in in quantum mechanics
um in for instance uh
you price in the last chapter his book
talks about virtual causality there is a
sort of the
the group of physicists in israel around
ireland of that things about retro
causality um
i don't know if this is what uh the
specific use of rhetorical
causality um there are
contexts in which it it seems natural
to use the notion of cause in reverse
um as i've argued the notion of course
is not
primitive it's a complicated story that
we have
because we assume that we can intervene
at some point
at fixed past and then we want to know
what happened according to the law of
physical record
of information about the future so
nothing prevents us to play the opposite
game
it just sounds uh unintuitive to us
because that's not the usual intuition
but i gave you an example in my talk
about virtual causality
if i want to say look i have my computer
simulation of what happened to the solar
system in the past
and i i i see that there is a not just a
solar system to our region of the galaxy
in the past i see some clouds
and i say oh this is a cloud that is
caused by the sun in the future
this is the cows the sun that is caused
by andromeda in the future
that's retro causality we're just
reading out
uh in a different way some objective
relation between
in that case objective relations because
that's classical
uh uh between the the position of mata
in
the galaxy in in our region
it doesn't it doesn't make sense because
we don't think in terms of
intervention toward the past because we
cannot intervene in the past
because this is going to know
thermodynamics but there's nothing
intuitively contradictory in it
um so um i i think
there are two more questions are you
game to go keep going
okay i'm i'm yeah happy to have you this
is
these questions are great um uh yeah
we'll give you a question
does the trace question lead to ib
identity question if there's no identity
are there no traces
i don't know which identity he means
that
you mean identity identity of objects
identity of people what what is
what is identity being um
i don't know i think we can ask him to
type uh
while we get that clarified
i can uh move on i can answer maybe i
can answer
generically i
let let me take identity in the in in
the sense
of you know permanence versus
um in in the sense in which this pen is
the same pen
one minute before one minute later
uh so this is the identity of the pen i
i
as a physicist i interpret identity
across
time just as
us similarity
that we
similarity between a process to repeat
itself
so in a sense yes we we
we identify object because we recognize
something we call an object now with
something
about which we have the traces and much
more strongly
i think that the sense of identity um
personally we have as our self is deeply
deeply rooted in the fact that we have
memories so
we have a story a story about ourselves
and this is what
what we are what i am is the symbol of
things i remember and
i tell a narration about myself so
traces are
in all sense ingredients for for
memories both at the level of
uh personal identity and object identity
i had the i had the clarification
which is in the sense of differentiation
right so so um
i think the pen example is a good one so
yeah
so you know i i think of the world it's
a symbol of
events processes which are punctual or
short in time
so it sees traces what glues different
um
events to make uh an object and you
different
objects by using the information you
have about them in the past
that's that's the way i think that
seemed to me
a natural way we can think especially at
the light of your quantum
theory field theory and the way physics
describe the world
today which is not objects it's more
it's more processes
more events so um the final question
before we wrap
up and it's from paul grimstad one he so
he has a comment about hume and cause
so hume skepticism about induction was
premised on the idea that we never have
an experience of the cause as such
all we have are the regularities the
constant conjunction
of one thing following another in such a
picture one cannot rationally justify
predictions about what will happen in
the future because you cannot assume the
future will resemble the past
and further you cannot assume induction
itself will continue to function i guess
stably as it had in the past
what does it mean to locate or see
causal power
itself for physics and thus get beyond
hume skepticism
that the idea of causal power was just
piece of metaphysics that
does not actually describe anything in
nature
ah fantastic fantastic question yes
oh yeah yeah a fantastic question
because let me answer as a physicist
the answer is no i mean for offices you
don't go beyond
hume at all i mean you don't want to go
beyond you
um there is no causation
beyond the
the regularities and induction
and of induction of course we know that
it fails right you know you know the
famous russell
uh turkey uh inductionist
who who every morning the the pace and
give him
uh food so he make a law of nature that
every morning the
patient is come to go drink food until
the day the morning the
patient comes in and
killed the turkey so induction fails we
know that induction fails
uh but that's it we know that the world
of physics fail
exactly the same sense it's exactly like
russell turkey and newton
newton law failed generativity is going
to fail in
in now we don't know
and this could be a good question for a
physicist why
induction fails so little
um i don't have an answer to that as a
scientist
i i don't know an answer in in
philosophy i don't find convincing any
answer
that tries to ground
causation or laws or anything else
in something beyond regularity precisely
because induction fails
so the answer to uh
to this great question
the question it's uh it's what allows uh
a scientist to go beyond um huge
skepticism about uh
uh about position which is a skeptic
thing about the the reliability of
induction
and the answer is nothing at all i don't
want to go go beyond
beyond that i want to keep the the
syrian skepticism
and of course you never said that
because of that you should not expect
the sun to rise tomorrow
you should expect the sun rise tomorrow
right because induction works very well
but you're not certain that the sun will
rise tomorrow and are we certain that
the sun is right tomorrow of course
we're not
right but i mean isn't this also tied to
the fact that we call something a law
precisely when it is stable
it has to be so the regularity
of the law is that it has stable
explanatory power and just as you said
very nicely with the sun example we know
that we have a very high chance of
expecting that the sun will rise
tomorrow but is there a guarantee
no yes uh exactly and i think that
there is a con there is a confusion
a recurring confusion philosophy
um there was a recent talk by
john norton
on the notion of possibility where he
had a great rhetorical attack the notion
of possibility defined
as everything is possible which is not
logically impossible
um i i was very sympathetic with him
um we don't use possibility in that
sense in our
daily life and we don't use possibility
of that sense in science
uh certain lack of certainty doesn't
mean lack of knowledge
right that's the key point yeah uh
what are what am i certain about zero
okay what i have knowledge about a huge
amount of things
you know i know that my name is carlo i
know that this is a computer i know that
the
earth is spherical what am i certain
about nothing
so the lack of certainty which is the
lack of a guarantee to the
absolute solidity of our of of our uh
it's it's uh uh it doesn't exist but
this doesn't take away any
of the reliability of the knowledge we
have including
uh the reliability of the maxwell
equations in their domain application
and
and and so on and so forth so i think
that
we can be human in this sense with
with respect to position um
and uh we can be union for the
fundamental level
with respect to the laws of physics just
expressing regularity this is the
extrapolation uh and rely on the fact
that uh by induction once again
we have seen how stable are
this kind of regularity that that that
we find without for
this reason asking philosophy to find a
next
reason for giving us a certainty which
if we had
it would be nefarious because it will
block us from being open to the
possibility
that there is something else going on
that we could understand better
great so um thank you very much
carlos for this wonderful talk and
real clear explanations and for helping
us
sort out some very thorny issues about
we have about which we have a lot of
misconceptions
and as you said a lot of it has to do
with
the nuances of meaning and of using
words that
don't mean the same thing in many
different contexts
so before i thank you let me just
advertise the continuing conversation
that is going to happen tomorrow so we
have at the same time at 3 p.m tomorrow
with the same zoom link that you use
today
uh you can come up come for a follow-up
discussion
uh with eric winsberg and we'll just
delve a little bit deeper
uh into and you know we had some
excellent questions and i'm sure that a
lot of these directions will be explored
in much more detail
and uh before i leave i just wanted to
flash to you this website for our
project
and the list of speakers upcoming
speakers
uh over the years so it's a monthly
colloquium series and uh
follow-up discussion so uh please come
and attend those and so i want to
thank everyone for uh coming today and
participating
and carlo delighted we would have been
much more excited of course if we had
all met in person
we would have had a very nice reception
and
lovely food and wine after this um
in one of those beautiful sort of old
yale buildings
but till then till uh next time till
that happens
uh we are delighted that you were able
to take the time to join us today
it will happen in the in in the future
thank you very much for everything it
was wonderful
and uh we were far away which perhaps
allowed more people to come so which was
really good and i'm very grateful and
thank you for this especially this
extraordinary set of questions at the
end that would make me think for a while
thank you very much bye bye everyone and
see you all tomorrow
bye ciao